foreign
[Music]
families in line for a ride we're gonna
call them family one family one family
one family one is in line for this ride
they get a a pretty good amount into the
line where they're you know almost to
the front Okay one of the girls in this
family realizes that they left their
phone in the uh I guess like you know
little Hoveround motorized thingy oh no
I thought in the scooter very normal
forgot a phone so it leaves the line to
go get the phone I gotta go get the
phone I gotta go get it before someone
Jacks it or whatever so she goes back
and gets her phone
comes back to the line and starts going
oh excuse me I just need to get through
to my family that happens a lot yeah all
the time I hate when it happens I hate
it but acceptable family too
does not want to let her do yo you're
cutting what the [ __ ] yeah family two
denies her Passage
and they get into a little bit of an
argument because they're not the
official wall trolls right yeah so
family two family two is not cool with
this they don't let her pass they get
into a little bit of a they don't fight
or anything but they're you know it's
abrasive giving them [ __ ] it's a quarrel
sure
afterwards
family one has already been on the ride
or whatever or maybe not but for some
weird reason family two goes out and
waits for family one to get out to find
that family and start [ __ ] with them
they start yelling did family one go on
the ride without her hold on a second
that's the most petty [ __ ] I've ever
heard I know you let people go through
the line who gives a [ __ ] but you know
how big Disneyland is this busy World by
the way oh my God they [ __ ] wasted
their whole day chasing this family is
huge but the thing that's weird is that
family two who didn't let that girl on
is the one that wants to wait and try to
catch yeah family two wants to start
some [ __ ] yeah so family two really
wants to start some [ __ ] so family one
runs into family two they start fighting
and it goes into an all-out brawl oh no
check this out yeah fight video tell us
which ones family one and which one
family two
oh one of the families is wearing a
uniform yeah people do that at Disney
sometimes the uniform families family
too yeah the other one's family Juan
family Juan this is not okay man that's
wild yeah their fighting sucks it has to
be better
oh that guy's nice and silver though
he's trying to break it up who's that
guy I think he's just a random guy this
is crazy bro he's not in the gear
oh
hey but this is family [ __ ] so it's
family two the green the green shirt
family the family too the one that
blocked the girl from coming in and also
waited are the ones in the red shorts
white shirts this is not worth it but
that's the thing though like obviously
they're gonna scrap even more by the way
they're attacking their phone we're a
quarter of the way into this video we
didn't watch the whole thing is it just
a bunch of adults or is there any kids
there this video is three minutes long
that's how long this fight lasts you
know why this is so stupid is like I
understand when people get angry and
they get heat and they want to fight
that all makes sense but the you have
any idea how expensive these tickets are
yeah dude number one it's expensive and
the objective of that day is to have fun
and be happy
now the objective is to rep your family
and have memories for life oh look this
is my line down you down you down we
down yeah Disney world's supposed to be
Unforgettable right yeah
let's make memories I hate any situation
where you think it's okay to fight where
like kids can just see it but they
anyone have the Mickey ears because
that'd be so sick then they make your
shirt it looks like and in the Mickey
Club costume I mean they should have the
red shorts the white top the Mickey
gloves the [ __ ] Mickey ears and
they're all fighting Mickey Mouse comes
out Blows the Whistle yeah they got
monkey gloves on yeah look at team wins
first round three minutes let's go
after they said for the kids too yeah
man kids could get hurt like this is
wild this is not okay yeah I just don't
understand like the objective is to have
fun that day there there are times where
you I think it's okay to defend your
honor there's like you know I know it
sounds really stupid and childish but
there's a certain level of Pride that
people have right if they want to defend
it that's fine yeah this is not one of
those situations at Disneyland out of
all places but also there's other things
to fight other families for at
Disneyland for other reasons like you
don't fight them because they're trying
to get through the line yeah yeah like
if they actually stole your phone then
you're like but we don't know the words
that were interchanged in those moments
you know what I mean like that person
coming back through the line can be like
you [ __ ] wait right here and I will
[ __ ] own your ass when my family gets
out you know what I mean we have no idea
what might have been like triggered or
said or even then though like listen
like I've learned this from my lady
right like because you know when we
first got together at a very short
temper and so she's like look how much
you ruined the day because
that's what my wife says to me too
look how much you ruined we were out
here I know that person said something
super disrespectful but now our whole
day is [ __ ] we came out here to go on
a date and now you ruined the [ __ ]
day was it worth it and I'm like you
know what you're right it wasn't [ __ ]
worth it were they wrong yes if I was by
myself maybe it might have been okay but
the objective of that day was for us to
go on a date and we were out and we're
supposed to have fun I could have let
that go and nothing would have happened
yeah wow this is a new David yeah I just
listen this is who I am I grow you plant
a seed you put in some soil I grow yeah
this is what I do you're not even angry
anymore I don't do that stuff anymore
unless his name is Dylan
guys I don't like to be angry anymore
that was the point either man I I want
to waste that on other things that's
productive yeah like busting it down
yeah there you go it definitely sucks if
you're going out of your way to like
create this fight like they went and
waited and were like let's get them when
they come out like did they both go on
the ride and there's like that picture
you know on the long run and both
families they're all side by side
if the two logs are going down and
they're like [ __ ]
side by side locks yeah I mean I guess
like the waiting time is really [ __ ]
long it's like an hour and 40 minutes
yeah imagine like when it was like
really far up they're all the way and
it's Florida it's hot as [ __ ] so I can
see and now you can't go there anymore
but it's understandable when one person
is just trying to meet their family
versus like a whole yeah yeah I've never
seen anyone stop the one person no I've
never seen it either I've seen people
feel like they want to but they don't do
it my mama [ __ ] you bro like wait in
line like all of them
see like a lot of people do
it it gets kind of fishy I'll tell you
this though when I was going to Taiwan
and you know during the Customs part
there are Chinese people that come
through and they don't like lines let me
tell you from China yeah I hate them
I'll tell you this [ __ ] though because I
feel like because I'm American right I'm
a little more verbose but literally at
first there was like a family that went
to the front right and I thought that
they were connecting with their other
family but they weren't no and they were
trying to trail with their other 10
members and we were already waiting in
line for like [ __ ] 40 minutes I took
my suitcase I went boom like [ __ ]
Gandalf I was like no go back
yeah you shall not
passed out and so it stopped it I was
like no you need to go back because at
this point to your country is what I
said yes
exactly right let them know let them
know hey open your eyes get the [ __ ] out
of here dude they're like this is our
country too yeah hey Corona get the [ __ ]
back here dude cough over there but stop
them and they had to go back because
everybody was unsure if they were just
trying to connect with their family all
right but they were all the way in the
[ __ ] bedroom they were shoving people
like yeah yeah but you know I'm like the
biggest guy there and I stopped I was
like no go back and then obviously
Mariel she speaks Mandarin and then I
told her to translate in a nice way and
then they went back Muriel translate
but she the thing was too it's like if
you tell them they'll stop but they're
trying to get away with it that's the
weird thing is that that's what they
told me when I was in China we went to
this place on Happy Land which is like a
[ __ ] Chinese amusement park another
Chinese McDonald's and all the time any
line you're in for a ride there's gonna
be like whole families of Chinese people
that just go like this and yes but if
you don't say anything they just take
okay and then our guide was like hey you
guys gotta tell these people like I'm
like you're the [ __ ] Chinese guy he's
like he goes I know I know but that's
that's a culture like you have to stop
them or they they'll just take what they
can get and then they go all right you
got me dude you got me yeah no it's
literally like that that's how it is and
then we started doing that and that's
what they would do they would just go uh
fair game fair game you got me hey to be
fair there's logic there yeah kind of
fire they don't even dignify it with an
excuse as of why they were doing that
they just stopped doing it and they go
oh you know what's crazy that's like how
they drive over there right yeah but but
I say this like you know in a weird way
because I've said this before on this
channel right it's like here there's
rules so when somebody so when you think
there's rules ever you think you assume
everybody's gonna follow the rule so
it's like it's my right of way you [ __ ]
up [ __ ] you right over there no rules so
when there's no rules you're always
paying attention and then it's like
things don't move as fast but then
there's like not really as many
accidents yeah you know what I'm saying
so I would assume it's like that in the
sense where it's like no rules until
somebody says you can't do it oh okay
it's so [ __ ] big too like especially
like in like the country dude there's
this video of it was like these Mainland
um Chinese people that were on a train
and Hong Kong right and they they were
spitting in the train and this lady I
get you could see the translation she's
like you take that [ __ ] Mainland
Chinese [ __ ] on there this is Hong Kong
you don't
you don't [ __ ] ripping into them
because they don't understand the
[ __ ] rules it's just so big in China
you know like when you're in the country
you could piss [ __ ] anywhere dude
remember when we were at the [ __ ]
Onsen hotel in Nagoya and then the tour
bus of Chinese people came in and we're
just quietly like slurping our ramen and
they just [ __ ] came in like a team of
locusts just going crazy like they're
just like [ __ ] rowdy I'm like dude
they're having a [ __ ] blast man and
they're just getting all their food and
[ __ ] and then you see this Japanese
family like shocked because they've
never seen anything like it before and
they're just like what oh [ __ ] and
they're just like quietly eating and
[ __ ] trying to hide we stopped off
dude in Beijing before we left and uh we
had business class tickets so we were in
the the lounge area right so the first
time that I was there on the way we
stopped in Beijing on the way there and
then on the way back it was super nice
it was very quiet on the way back we we
got there around like 1pm their time dog
I'm talking about there was a guy being
dragged out because he was trying to eat
the food in the in the business class
area and he wasn't supposed to be there
and he was screaming like I said there's
some kind of logic here I like yeah he
goes all right you got me you got me
yeah and he's like I don't know what
he's saying because obviously I don't I
don't speak I can't think but he was
just like he got I just of it no but he
started grabbing all the [ __ ] I
forgot some egg and [ __ ] mac and
cheese my germs
he was just screaming and it was so
rowdy it was so I was like what the [ __ ]
happened and it was just it was a lot of
like Mainland Chinese people that were
just I wonder if they come to America
and they go back like Americans are
crazy yeah it's funny because we do
mirror that in some ways Americans are
that for every other country like 100
plus like even on the freeway let's say
like it's traffic right and one guy just
takes the [ __ ] emergency lane and
then expects to be let in right here
someone's gonna [ __ ] let him in
that's kind of the same thing as what
happens at the buffet yeah you know in
China it's like and then when you don't
let him in all he does is wait till the
next guy lets him in like the rules
don't get broke it's not like he's gonna
reverse yeah but that's like what white
people are like when I see them in like
Japan and Korea when I was in Korea
recently we were on the train and they
don't understand certain etiquette which
to us is very common sense like I'm not
I don't live in Korea but I understand
that when it's quiet shut the [ __ ] up
and and when it's time to talk you talk
so during the stops
um people will talk they'll get you know
say what they want a little louder and
then when people when the Train's going
that's when they start to be quiet and
there's like uh one person was like from
the UK and the other person the other
two people were from the U.S and they
saw each other because they're both
white and they got super excited like
dude where are you from [ __ ] loud as
[ __ ] it's 7 A.M in the morning right
loud as [ __ ] [ __ ] like dude it's so
amazing here I just tapped him on the
shoulder what does mine say
so literally I just tapped him on the
shoulder I was like
cut it out it's too loud you see
everybody else they're quiet and they're
like but they were talking I was like
yeah during the stops but you're [ __ ]
loud shut the [ __ ] up all right because
literally like respectfully shut the
[ __ ] up I was just irritate it because
they're not they refused to read the
room because they could see it but
they're ignoring it you know what I mean
right so once I see them do this they go
uh they just get louder and louder
because nobody's saying anything oh so
so you do know so now you're speaking
about an [ __ ] so you just want the
attention yeah and so they just got
really quiet they're like oh I'm so I
was like you knew it though so just come
on right yeah just kind of annoying
let's let's ask the important questions
though yeah what do you think of Chinese
people I love them
it's funny because the most [ __ ] that
I've heard people talk about Chinese
people is always from Chinese people
yeah yeah they [ __ ]
in Taiwan like Chinese people in Taiwan
have a derogatory term for the Chinese
yeah yeah so it's Chinese people talking
[ __ ] about Chinese I think every country
they see them as animals like what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah I think it's also
because I think like a lot of Asian
countries have a lot of pride in their
country so when they see somebody
misrepresent who they are oh and the
whole world gets to see that it pisses
them off it's like this is not who we
are like you have to understand like
China has such a rich [ __ ] culture
thousands of thousands of thousands of
[ __ ] years old you look at [ __ ]
Pottery for crying out loud right you
look at their temples like it's [ __ ]
amazing but then all we see is somebody
[ __ ] on a train
that's good content yeah my boy right
here when I when I was in China all of
this like stereotype about mainlander
obnoxiousness and bad tourists it didn't
exist because I was in Beijing and all
these other cities and like I mean yeah
there's like pickpockets and [ __ ] but
people were chill there were lines at
McDonald's people respected the order I
don't know what you know what happened
but then you do see crazy tour buses
that come out and they're just like
Wilding and I'm like what the [ __ ] I
didn't see you guys when I went to China
well I think people gotta remember like
again I I've said this before China's
got like 1.6 billion yeah right
variation so you're gonna see every
[ __ ] version of human existence from
the stuff you like to the stuff you
absolutely despise it's gonna be there
period like I [ __ ] love China but
it's gonna have the darkest places and
the lightest places as well I've got all
the Walmart Chinese [ __ ] going on
vacation though in all the countries
[ __ ] it all over
that's probably what they're saying
about the Americans too no because in
America they just stay in the States you
know what I mean like yeah all Walmart
people don't go to [ __ ] around you
know yeah well actually you never know
dude American tourists are
Walmart people just go to Cancun or
Thailand but they're not going to Europe
and all like Asia and Japan and [ __ ] I
think there's there's also got to be
some kind of correlation between
population density and taking what I can
get the attitude for sure there has to
be because isn't India like that too I
heard that it was like a lot of people
it's just people every man for
themselves yeah there has to be
something I've never seen an Indian guy
take a [ __ ] on the street at UCLA that's
true that's different oh yeah they did
there was like a TED Talk that I watched
about this Indian guy was trying to
solve the problem of Indians like uh
[ __ ] everywhere kind of a thing oh
you saw that yo so check this out so uh
Ted talk huh yeah Mariel when she was in
Taiwan on studying abroad right one of
the study abroad people they were from
India and he was from a rural rural town
and so he would piss and [ __ ] in a
bucket he would throw it out the window
right I mean that just sounds like 16th
century Europe to me it was like it was
like like in that and then of course
like he didn't know right but he's from
a rural country I mean like the country
bumpkin ass area and they're like you
can't do this oh we get rid of our waste
this was like no no use the toilet but
he didn't [ __ ] know right so he was
just doing stuff that was in his comfort
zone right a lot of this stuff is like
an education thing yeah that stuff is
always forgivable the first time in my
opinion but he did it for three years
then it's his friends his friends are
the problem there's a hot dog stand out
there not again
foreign